[Music]
all right well now let's turn to the
Bill Cosby sexual assault trial the jury
was deadlocked last night after four
days of deliberation but today in the
courtroom the legal battle took another
turn
today the 79 year old actor held on to
his publicist for support while arriving
at the Pennsylvania Court Cosby is
accused of drugging and molesting his
one-time protégé former Temple
University employee at college
basketball star andrea constand at his
home back in 2004 he's facing a possible
30-year prison sentence if found guilty
the jury in the case seems to be
struggling to reach a verdict yesterday
after 40 hours of deliberating they told
the judge they were deadlocked but the
judge asked them to keep trying to reach
a unanimous verdict and today they asked
to rehear testimony and for the
definition of reasonable doubt if the
jury cannot reach a unanimous decision a
mistrial will be declared if that
happens is up to prosecutors to decide
if they want to retry the case well this
has been an incredibly dramatic trial
but take a look at this that's Andrea
and she managed to blow off some steam
by making a perfect switch and what
appears to be the courthouse hallway
Andrea is a former college basketball
star who also managed the women's team
at Temple University
you